grab a mortar and pestle to make a spicy
marinade for the chicken crack open
cardamom pods and add
ground ginger
coriander
cinnamon grated nutmeg
clove of garlic
fresh coriander
lemon juice
olive oil
and seasoning
now pulverize to form a paste
pour over the chicken thighs and leave
some marinade for up to two hours
[Music]
to cook griddle in a high heat to get
wonderfully charred meat
[Music]
[Applause]
once the chicken is cooked warm through
tortilla wraps on the same griddle
then simply slice your chicken
[Music]
and put your wrap together
top with threaded cabbage
[Applause]
chopped spring onion
and your favorite chili sauce
[Music]